So far, you've defined the profile entity class in
your application. We don't actually yet do anything with it.
The next step is to add the code to saveProfiles
in the datastore. But you've already been working in the
conference api.java class and remember that it defines a saveProfle
method, which doesn't actually yet do any saving. But it
will, when we're done with it. The next step is
to actually write the code, that saves the entity in
the datastore. And it's marked in the file for
you as TODO 3. But before I set you
loose to do that, I just want to review
how to save entities in the datastore using objectify.
Okay. So, we're going to look at how to
save entities in the datastore using objectify. You use
your objectify service. The, the ofy method, you call
the save method, call the entity method passing the entity
to actually save and then, now. The now means,
go ahead and do it right now. It's usual
practice to define a static ofy method, so you
can simplify the code like this. Just call ofy. So,
if you remember we talked about recipes a little
while ago. Here's how you might save a recipe. So,
this assumes that we've created a recipe entity bound
with variable recipe one, so we just pass in recipe
one as the entity to save, and there it is.